what's going on guys this is Rob and
Spider-Man into the spider-verse 2 comes
out this weekend and while I have not
seen the movie yet what better way to
celebrate than to run over every version
of Spider-Man that we know anything
about in Marvel Comics and even some
outside of Marvel Comics and fingers
crossed we see them in the movie
supposedly they're supposed to be like
250 different versions of Spider-Man
although only a handful will probably
see in any meaningful way but let's kick
our list off right so coming off the top
is Spider-Man from a universe that some
of you guys may not know what the
numerical designation is but I guarantee
you're familiar with it the Ultimate
Spider-Man cartoon show and I chose this
one because a lot of you guys probably
grew up with that show or at least we're
kicking the list off because a lot of
you guys grew up with that show I
personally did not but it is phenomenal
Why not start things off there now
coming out of that one we've got Earth
92131 this is Spider-Man from the 1990s
Animated Series this is the one that I
grew up on it was a phenomenal show then
it's a phenomenal show now it still
holds up but X-Men the Animated Series
is better but coming out of Earth
6799 this is the 1960s Spider-Man
animated cartoon show now for those of
you guys who aren't really familiar with
why that one matters so much that's
where the now famous Spider-Man intro
song comes from Spider-Man Spider-Man
does whatever a spider can that show is
what made it popular now Earth one two
zero seven zero three this is the Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man universe I'm gonna
get a lot of flack for saying this I
will not apologize Andrew Garfield's
Spider-Man is better than Toby and toms
no I'm not gonna apologize for it it's
amazing I love that version of
Spider-Man but coming out of Earth
96283 this is Toby McGuire's Spider-Man
universe and then coming out of Earth
one with a whole bunch of nines is Tom
Holland's Spider-Man universe also known
as the Marvel Cinematic Universe I don't
care what Kevin feige and those guys say
it is not earth 616 is Earth one nine
whatever all the different nines that
come after it who cares one nine
repeating that's just the way that it is
now of course Earth 65 is the spider
Gwen Universe now of course a lot of you
guys know about spider Gwen from
Spider-Man into the spider-verse her
popularity was actually unintentional a
little bit of fun history here when
spider Gwen popped up on the scene it
was actually the design of her costume
that made her incredibly popular right
just the cover art it was phenomenal
when that comic book came out you could
not go to a Comic-Con without seeing
every white chick between the ages of 16
and 27 cosplaying as spider-gwen
admittedly it was cool to see the
Phantom just rallying around a singular
character like that but her character
has remained popular ever since of
course she come comes from a universe
where she received abide at the hands of
a radioactive spider instead of Peter
Parker and in fact in that reality Peter
Parker became the lizard and then she
ultimately ended up killing him now
Earth
3145 is from the main spider-verse event
that is an Earth where Uncle Ben becomes
Spider-Man you didn't really know a
whole lot about his reality all we knew
is that he operated a Spider-Man for
quite some time he's the one that
received the bite from a radioactive
spider instead of Peter Parker when he
went with Peter to the science exhibit
the problem here is that he referred to
it as the Emerald elf which was
basically his universe's version of the
Green Goblin the Green Goblin killed
Peter and Aunt May and then following
that basically Uncle Ben quit but when
all the inheritors were running around
the spider-verse and they were killing
Spider-Man everywhere he ended up
retreating to what was basically a
bunker during that time the Doctor
Octopus of his reality basically
initiated a World War and the entirety
of the world was laid waste and just
filled with radiation but from Earth
this is actually a reimagining of
Spider-Man's origin which was initially
considered to be in continuity but was
later moved to its own Universe this
story was known as Spider-Man chapter
one it was a really cool story I don't
know why Marvel got rid of it but from
Earth 15 this actually includes
different variations of Spider-Man like
the spider this is known as the Exiles
now the reason why I say earth 15 and
reference the Exiles is because in
Marvel Comics the Exiles was actually
one of the coolest Concepts ever created
the gist behind this is that the Exiles
were actually a multiversal team that
was composed of different characters
from different realities from Earth 15
this version of Spider-Man known as the
spider was actually a Peter Parker who
had essentially merged with the Carnage
symbiote and ended up becoming a killer
it was really really amazing but Earth
8101 introduces us to spider monkey this
is actually a version of Spider-Man
where basically he's a monkey but he
actually kills villains because in that
reality the idea is that if villains
cannot be redeemed they're executed and
that's just the way that it is but Earth
2301 gives us the manga verse and in the
manga verse we basically have manga
Spider-Man this is a version of
Spider-Man that's actually a ninja and
seeks revenge against the villainous
Ronin known as Venom it is a phenomenal
Story one of the best stories that
Marvel's written ever in the history of
Marvel with regards to Spider-Man but
Earth
58163 gives us a world where Spider-Man
masquerades as a mutant in order to fit
into a society dominated by mutants
entirely But ultimately his identity is
exposed by J Jonah Jameson and if you're
familiar with Marvel Comics you guessed
it this is House of M and it's one of
the greatest stories that Marvel's ever
done people seem to get get a little
finicky when I never like talk about how
crappy a story is I mean there's
definitely bad stories and in fact in
this list we're going to run over over
one of the darkest stories ever in the
history of Marvel but coming out of
Earth
trn566 this is actually a continuation
of the 1990 Spider-Man cartoon show now
here's the reason why Marvel uses TRN
when it comes to their Universe
designations anytime an alternate
reality is created but it's not fully
explored or sometimes even that line of
comics is canceled Marvel will not give
it an alternate reality designation now
it's not as though the entirety of
Marvel editing sits around and says this
is what the numerical designation would
be it's usually just a writer that
actually just throws in the name or at
least the number of the universe but
because that was never done with regards
to this we don't actually get a
definitive explanation it's just simply
a temporary reality numbering until
someone comes along and officially
establishes that it's based off an
existing Universe it kind of is but some
of the stories in this comic actually
deviated from the original Source
material so it's not necessarily tied
directly in line with the original 1990s
cartoon Universe continuity but coming
out of this we get Earth 2818 which
basically gives us cyborg Spider-Man but
what this guy is is effectively an
almost carbon copy of Spider-Man as you
know him the difference is he has
cybernetic Parts instead of just organic
human parts they do Grant him differing
powers to various degrees but still his
role is more or less the same now of
course the next one that we get is the
earth 616 Spider-Man but not the one
that you think of course because that's
mostly obvious the main Marvel Universe
Spider-Man why would we add that on this
list so this is superior Spider-Man and
this guy's phenomenal so superior
Spider-Man was actually the result of a
story called dying wish which Marvel had
been building up to for quite some time
in effect Dr Octopus was dying and so in
order to keep himself alive he swapped
bodies with Peter Parker so Peter
Parker's mind was placed in the body of
the dying Doctor Octopus and and then
ultimately the body passed away and the
mind of Dr Octopus was put in the body
of Peter Parker in this line of comics
which didn't last all too long only
about two and a half maybe three years
this gave us one of the greatest
Redemption arcs of Dr Octopus in history
he went from a guy who was basically
just a villain running around a
Spider-Man and doing villainous stuff to
what effectively became a superhero and
starting Parker Industries so for those
of guys who read all new all different
Spider-Man and you don't know how Peter
Parker became a billionaire that's
because of superior Spider-Man Dr
Octopus said all that stuff in motion
but
earth40081 is actually just a reality
where Peter Parker was bitten by a
radioactive spider but never actually
got any powers and in fact this is from
a story arc called powerless instead all
that really happens here is this hand
just atrophies but Earth 1610 which we
will revisit here in a little bit is the
home of the Ultimate Spider-Man Peter
Parker this was basically just a 2000's
reworking of Peter Parker and the Marvel
Mythos that was done in a way to answer
the question what would it look like if
in the year 2000 superheroes were
popping up for the very first time a lot
of the themes and a lot of the
motivations and a lot of the ideas of
the characters were updated to reflect
the Modern Age ultimately he ended up
dying but this version of Spider-Man is
one of the most celebrated in the
history of Marvel Comics and to this day
despite the fact that his character was
killed off he still has a ridiculously
devoted fan base but Earth 34281 this
gives us a version of Peter Parker that
was actually abused by his uncle then as
a child and ends up striking a deal with
what's effectively a kind of spider
demon in his basement and actually ends
up going forward as Spider God and so
this leads us into a universe that
houses a storyline that's one of my
absolute favorites this is Earth 295 and
in this reality Spider-Man is actually
executed it by the apocalypse regime for
allying with those individuals who stand
against apocalypse specifically this is
the 1995 Age of Apocalypse storyline I
love this storyline the human High
Council Magneto's X-Men the mkron
crystal all those things Legion Quest
and so on it's a great story but
following this we go to Earth 311 which
is one of the most popular stories that
Marvel's written and in fact you're
going to see this story floating around
as a major Point within Marvel what if
season two and in this universe
Spider-Man serves as an apprentice to
the Royal spymaster in the Marvel
1602 universe so that's really really
cool hopefully again we'll see this
character within spider-verse into the
spider-verse too but then we switch over
to earth 13. now Earth 13 is an
alternate reality that's predicated on a
different set of events but based on the
main Marvel Universe specifically a
story called acts of Vengeance and in
this story this basically dealt with the
villain Loki or at least he was a
Villain at the time bringing together
all the different villains for the
purpose of attacking and destroying the
superheroes obviously it didn't work
think of it as like a less successful
version of what we saw in Old Man Logan
when Red Skull did the same thing but
then it actually succeeded so in the
acts of engine storylines one of the
things that had happened is that Loki
had unleashed the tri Sentinel in the
city of New York in response to this
Peter Parker was granted something
called the Enigma Force I.E he became
Captain Universe the Enigma Force is
literally a source of power that we
hardly know anything about that's why
Marvel gave it that name so they never
really have to explain it but a person
who has the power of the Enigma Force
can do a wide variety of different
things ultimately he lost that power but
not before he punched the Incredible
Hulk into space Earth 13 is actually an
answer to the the question what if he
never lost that ability and in fact
during this spider-verse event Earth 13
serves as a kind of safe haven for all
the different members of the spider Army
that are either fleeing from the
inheritors or trying to Marshal their
forces building battle formations
whatever the case happens to be at least
it stays that way until the leader of
the inheritors Solace shows up and kills
that Spider-Man and then all bets are
off and they're all just fleeing for
their lives for what's basically the
rest of the story now Earth 772 gives us
a follow-up to the original Amazing
Spider-Man story where Peter Parker
tried to join the Fantastic Four and
where he was initially given the boot By
the Fantastic Four and refused to be
allowed onto the team just due to his
Youth and inexperience Earth 772 gives
us an answer to the question what if he
was brought on to the team and so
instead of it being the Fantastic Four
we're now introduced to the fantastic
five funny enough whatever you look up
the Fantastic Five itself you see Peter
Parker kind of there in the background I
know it's not supposed to look that way
but he just looks sad and dejected as if
he's onto the team but not really part
of the team which kind of makes sense
because a Fantastic Four is a family but
Earth 9602 is actually one of the more
interesting aspects in both Marvel and
DC Comics because this is what we refer
to as the amalgam universe and this came
out of a story called Marvel vs DC and
what it basically happened here is both
Peter Parker and Superboy actually fuse
to form Spider Boy and basically
exhibited all the spider powers that
we're familiar with which also included
telekinesis now Earth
10919 is actually an alternate reality
that kind of follows up to Civil War and
in effect instead of Peter Parker losing
the iron spider armor that he got from
Tony Stark during the Civil War event
and at the end of the Civil War event
when he turned against Tony and decided
to Ally with Captain America in this
reality he never loses the iron spider
suit now ultimately it's all for null
because because he's basically killed
when the inheritors are traveling across
the Multiverse in the spider-verse event
and killing different versions of
Spider-Man but Earth 2149 gives us one
of the more popular universes in the
entirety of Marvel Comics and in fact
this was a heavily anticipated episode
in Marvel what if season one this of
course is Marvel zombies and in this
universe we have a version of Peter
Parker that has a really gross power
instead of shooting webbing out of his
wrists he shoots veins out of his wrist
and that's how he swings around even now
it still gives me the willies now
following this we go into Earth 5701 and
in this universe not a whole lot to be
seen here instead this introduces us to
what's called pestilence Spider-Man this
basically introduces us to Peter Parker
who had become one of the horsemen of
apocalypse known as pestilence but Earth
1298 brings us to a relatively obscure
universe depending on how deep of a
reader you are when it comes to the
X-Men Mythos but also introduced us to
one of the most powerful Concepts in
existence of course that concept being
the goblin Force this particular story
is known as mutant X now in this story
Spider-Man doesn't really do a whole lot
to speak of instead he's basically just
the original sixth arm Spider-Man but he
never finds a way to cure himself so he
just spends the rest of his days walking
around with six arms but Earth 982 is a
very popular line of comics although I
think that's kind of waned in recent
years this is called Marvel Comics 2. so
Marvel Comics 2 was actually the idea of
the Ultimate Universe before the
introduction of the Ultimate Universe
the just behind Marvel Comics 2 was much
like with the Ultimate Universe to
retell the origins of characters in a
more updated way and to make Marvel more
accessible the other caveat of mc2 is
the characters were very similar to
their Earth 98 counterparts in the sense
that they aged in real time one and so
this actually gave us a version of Peter
Parker who's more of a supporting
character for his daughter who becomes
Spider-Girl named Mayday Parker and of
course for the most part she's basically
inherited all of his powers but Earth
70237 gives us an older Spider-Man who's
actually fighting against the city
that's been completely taken over by
Venom and what we now refer to as the
Spider-Man Reign storyline but Earth
9591 is probably one of the darkest
stories ever written in the history of
Marvel this is a story called Marvel
ruins and this particular comic book
Spider-Man is actually trying to become
or at least gain powers like so many
other people around him he basically
exposes himself to a radioactive spider
which bites him but then he ends up
dying of radiation sickness and actually
spreads this sort of radioactive rash to
various people including the guy who's
going around and documenting how dark
and terrible things are Bruce Banner
being exposed to the gamma bomb and then
turning into a giant irradiated mass of
tumors Steve Rogers going crazy from the
super soldier serum if you don't have
just some overwhelming desire to read
this story I would kind of suggest you
stay away from it but if you're
interested in torturing yourself you
will find a link to it down in the
comments section now the next universe
is one that you guys may be familiar
with on some level due to the first
Spider-Man into the spider-verse movie
this one focuses on Marvel Noir
Spider-Man Noir is just one part of that
Universe now there's a whole X-Men Noir
and everything it's really really cool
and in fact we should probably cover it
here on the channel because it's
basically just a kind of answer to the
question what would the universe look
like if superheroes were popping up
during the time of the Great Depression
but Earth
602-636 this is actually a world it
reimagines the relationship between
Spider-Man and Mary Jane Watson as a
Teenage Drama and despite the fact that
I'm gonna almost 40 year old man this
story is amazing
I love this story but Earth 999 is
actually a story that introduces us to
spider cat who's basically just a cat
that gains spider powers and then fights
a pigeon known as Venom which is an
equally Amazing Story it's every bit as
awesome as you think it is now following
this we go into Earth
50101 which is Spider-Man India and it's
a really cool concept the character
actually had a major role within
spider-verse and it was really just kind
of cool to see Marvel doing like
Multicultural representation they did
the same thing with giant size X-Men
back in 1975 so it was cool to see them
doing that with the Spider-Man universe
but following this we jump into Earth
one two one zero one and in this reality
Deadpool is fighting Spider-Man but the
fight is really more drawn out than it
needs to be and it's really more just
Deadpool kind of prolonging things and
when Peter Parker asked why Deadpool
says because he's just kind of enjoying
the moment and he's gonna do the thing
that makes the most logical sense in
terms of defeating Peter Parker he
shoots him in the face and then
following this he goes on a killing
spree across the Marvel Universe yes
ladies and gentlemen you guessed it this
is Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
but in Earth
2-1-205 this actually gives us an
alternate reality that's pretty tragic
that once Gwen Stacy's killed by the
Green Goblin Peter Parker freaks out and
then kills the Green Goblin but as a
coping mechanism he adopts the goblin
identity of his own specifically he
becomes the Hobgoblin so he basically
becomes a villain as a way of grieving
the death of Gwen Stacy pretty tragic
and kind of messed up but in Earth
87127 Flash Thompson is actually bitten
by the radioactive spider instead of
Peter Parker and he ends up becoming
Captain spider now on Earth 9997 this is
the home of a storyline that we started
never finished and people keep asking
for it this is Earth X and we should
finish it Universe X Paradise X those
stories were amazing this is a reality
where things are kind of
post-apocalyptic but also a little
hopeful at the same time but Peter
Parker is basically just an aging guy
who does have his daughter but is
effectively given up on superhero Antics
the hopeful aspect of it comes in the
fact that towards the end of the story
he ends up redawning his Spider-Man
costume and then goes out into The Fray
to become a superhero again the costume
doesn't quite fit and he's a little
older and fatter than he used to be but
it is adorable to see him trying to
recapture the glory of his younger days
now Earth 15901 is actually a reality we
know virtually nothing about all we know
is that by whatever Manner and whatever
means Peter Parker was somehow bitten by
a vampire and ended up becoming a
vampire Spider-Man we don't see him very
long he's killed and consumed by the
inheritors fairly quickly but Earth
trn458 this is a world that never
actually moved beyond the Medieval Age
and this version of Spider-Man prefers
to Simply maintain the status quo
instead of becoming a superhero this is
the spider Knight now Earth
70105 is actually a reality where Bruce
Banner was transformed into Spider-Man
when he was bitten by a gamma irradiated
spider but Earth
trn454 is actually a reality that was
initially introduced in the Spider-Man
Unlimited cartoon show that houses a
girl named Petra Parker and this is
where all the gender roles are reversed
specifically the men are women and the
women are men it was a phenomenal aspect
of that episode but Earth 8311 is of
course where spider ham comes from
because spider ham initially started off
as a spider and was bitten by a
radioactive Pig
and now he has his current form I know
it sounds weird it's very strange roll
with it it's just Comics but Earth one
three nine eight nine is actually a
timeline where superheroes turned into
werewolves and then developed a taste
for human flesh in this instance we're
introduced to spiderwolf now Earth 14512
is the introduction of Penny Parker who
Pilots the spider suit this universe is
based heavily on Neon Genesis and Anime
so it's one of the coolest versions of
the character that we've ever seen But
Earth 833 is actually the home of
Spider-Man UK also known as William
Braddock this guy is part of the Captain
Britain Corps which is effectively like
the Green Lantern Corps from DC Comics
except instead of each member of the
Captain Britain core monitoring like a
portion of their Universe they monitor
the whole universe which seems kind of
weird because Captain Britain's not very
powerful but this brings us to the final
two versions of Peter Parker which are
exceedingly Dark Earth 51412 is the home
of Patton Parnell who didn't actually
gain spider powers when he was bitten by
a radioactive spider instead he just
turned into like this giant grotesque
looking spider monster and when he ended
up biting his girl she basically woke up
from it all thinking he was a kind of
nightmare and as the story comes to a
close all these little spiders burst out
of her neck right and so it's it's crazy
it's creepy if you don't like spiders do
not read that comic book now of course
following this we get Earth
11580 and this is a version of
Spider-Man known as spider's man and
this guy is just a whole bunch of
spiders that operate with a hive mind
and make up a singular being one of the
other cool things about this this is one
of the most powerful versions of
Spider-Man we've ever seen because it's
almost impossible to kill this guy
because if you were to like shoot him
with a gun or something the spiders will
just kind of separate and make an
opening for the bullet to pass through
assuming they can move that fast it's
comic books right just one of those
weird things but following this we're
going to leave Peter Parker and we're
going to switch over to Miles Morales
and then Miguel O'Hara now one of the
funny things about this is there isn't a
whole lot of alternate reality
depictions of these characters one
because like Miguel O'Hara for example
already comes from an alternate reality
and two he's not as popular as Peter
Parker the same thing with Miles Morales
but also miles is fairly new so kicking
things off here there is Earth 1610.
this is the original reality of Miles
Morales in Marvel Comics and in fact
Miles Morales was introduced to us in a
story called ultimate Fallout in effect
what had happened is Peter Parker in the
Ultimate Universe had died and Miles
Morales had actually been bitten by a
radioactive spider as well but instead
of somebody just getting the same kind
of powers that Peter Parker had he got
the same kind of powers that you see in
like Spider-Man into the spider-verse
where he has this Venom blast he can go
invisible or at least kind of camouflage
himself more or less but he ended up
becoming that reality's version of
Spider-Man now after the events of
Secret Wars in 2015 Miles Morales
actually ended up crossing over into the
main Marvel Universe and it's basically
been there ever since but following this
we go into Earth eight and this is
actually a combination of a storyline as
well as a future possible alternate
reality we're miles and Gwen actually
get married and basically have a whole
life and a relationship together but
following this we go into Earth 61610
which is basically battle world and this
is the version of Miles Morales that
exists in the secret Wars battle world
event which is kind of a patchwork
planet made up of like different
alternate realities exactly which one of
those realities he's in I can't remember
off the top of my head so I'm not going
to give you a definitive answer but from
here we actually go into Earth
trn664. this is Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe again why because Marvel
was basically trying to find a way to
make more money so they gave us this
story which is really more of like a
half-ass cash grab but in this universe
Miles Morales is simply just shown to us
as one of the many superheroes that
Deadpool's killed a second time but
after this we go into Earth
trn517 which is actually one of the
coolest Concepts out there in Marvel
Comics known as the contest of Champions
now this version of miles is basically a
participant in the contest which is a
game that involves various Marvel
superheroes and villains all of whom
essentially fight to the death but Earth
1048 is Marvel's Spider-Man Miles
Morales Spider-Man video games the PS4
games and I just gotta say it I just
gotta throw it out here the Miles
Morales game is better than the first
one I love the story in that game it's
phenomenal it was shorter definitely but
I feel like it was better something that
I recently found out when I was talking
to Benny over at comic story apparently
it was supposed to be a DLC and they
just made it like a whole separate game
which is why it's not called Spider-Man
2 and that kind of makes sense the more
that I think about it but Earth trn571
this is the home of Spider-Man Shattered
Dimensions and while in this game miles
is not a playable character this version
is mentioned in the game as being part
of an alternate future but Earth TRN 700
is of course the home reality of
Spider-Man into the spider-verse right
the whole first film and presumably part
of the second film I don't know why
they'd start miles off in an alternate
reality but Earth TRN 765 is the home of
Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the black
order and of course in this version of
the game miles is a playable character
now following this we switch over to
Miguel O'Hara this is where we start to
wrap things up right Miguel O'Hara
actually comes from Earth 928 which is
the future of the main Marvel Universe
now you might be asking yourself why is
it referred to as Earth 928 if the main
novel universe is Earth 616 and it's in
the future of the main Marvel Universe
because when it comes to the Future in
Marvel Comics it's ever changing so
until we get to 2099 in Marvel Comics we
won't definitively know if that's
exactly how reality turns out and so for
the time being it's just one possible
future in the same way that Days of
Future Past is a possible future the Age
of Apocalypse is a possible future there
are all potential outcomes for the
current situation that's unfolding at
any given point in time in Marvel Comics
but the original Miguel O'Hara the way
he was depicted and largely continues to
operate in Marvel Comics is that he
doesn't actually have any Spider-Man
Powers instead his abilities are all
Technology based that he works for
alcamax corporation which is exceedingly
corrupt just like Facebook in the modern
era and that he actually works to
basically defeat the corrupt agenda of
the very company he works for now he
works for Alco Max because alchemax runs
everything right and so like unless you
want to be some vagrant standing on a
street corner with a sign asking for
money you're going to end up having to
work for alconax and so in the aftermath
of the original spider-verse event
Miguel O'Hara actually ended up in the
main Marvel Universe in the present day
and just kind of resided there for a
little while but there was an attempt in
Earth 96099 to actually re-imagine the
entirety of the 2099 Universe which was
basically called timestorm people didn't
like it the story was trash Marvel
scrapped it but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section thank you for
watching let me know if there's anybody
that I missed and I will catch you all
later
peace